Traductor: Daniel Moore
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Mucha de la historia de mi vida
y muchas escenas, han tenido que ver
con la pregunta de moverse o no moverse,
y eso es un tanto evidente, ¿no?
Yo puedo identificar escenas
concretas en que un instante
me han dejado quieto,
paralizado, asustado,
y a la vez muy movido por dentro.
Hoy les quiero compartir lo que aprendí
en uno de esos acontecimientos que
mueven por fuera, pero que sobre todo,
conmueven por dentro,
o por lo menos, a mí así me pasó.
A poco no hay lecciones que da la vida
que son importantes,
a veces a poco no hay de [esas] clases
que nos da la existencia,
que por alguna razón
son difíciles de olvidar,
y que te marcan.
Yo tuve la suerte, como muchos mexicanos,
de estar en ese examen sorpresa
que nos planteó la vida,
el 19 de septiembre del 2017
a las 13:14 horas.
¡Se siente horrible!
Yo llegó un momento en que sentí
que me caía de la silla de ruedas.
A mí, con toda sinceridad, el terremoto
me agarró comiendo un taco de cecina,
y el plan era recoger a Pablo,
mi hijo, para irnos a esquiar.
Solo para que vean mi inconsciencia,
así lo hice,
Recogí a Pablo, tuvimos que hasta dar
vuelta por un puente que se había caído.
Ahora, lo que me doy cuenta es, que
tal vez, tenía un miedo tan monstruoso,
que la mejor forma de defenderme
fue decir no pasa nada y continuar
con las actividades de ese día.
Entonces al día siguiente,
a la Cruz Roja a ayudar un poco.
Y un par de días después,
por la bendición de tener amigos
de esos que se pueden llamar locos útiles,
tuve la suerte de ir
con mi amigazo Carlos Clérico,
un ingeniero tanatólgo loco, a Jojutla.
El plan era ir con un grupo de maestros
cuya escuela se había caído.
Varios de ellos habían perdido
su casa y de las familias también,
algunos incluso
habían perdido algún familiar.
Fue muy impresionante llegar a Jojutla,
y era como llegar a una película
de la guerra, todo tirado, edificios
caídos, polvo por todos lados,
la alameda llena de casas de campaña,
y en la calle, muchísimas,
muchísimas personas de todos lados del país,
algunos extranjeros, muchos universitarios.
Tere, mi esposa, inteligente,
sensible, práctica y útil como es,
se puso con las directoras de la escuela
a hacer un plan para regresar a clases,
y para soñar una escuela renovada.
Yo estaba súper confundido, porque eso
de recoger piedras y escombros, la verdad,
no se me facilita mucho.
Entonces pensé que lo mejor
era aprenderle al Carlo,
y ayudar a las personas a recoger
sus escombros y a acomodar
sus escombros internos.
Y así empecé a trabajar y a participar
en grupos de acompañamiento en crisis.
Bueno, así se llaman, yo más bien
puedo decir que tuve el privilegio
de tomar cátedra con maestros
de resiliencia de Jojutla,
Zacatepec, Tlaltizapán,
Cuernavaca y Ciudad de México.
Y quisiera compartirles, en unos minutos,
tres lecciones que
esta experiencia me regaló.
Les comparto con cariño un ABC
de las lecciones que aprendí.
La A, A de abrir los ojos,
primero para ver para dónde salir
corriendo, en mi caso, rodar rápido,
(Risas)
pero también abrir los ojos para
asombrarnos de lo que estaba pasando.
A de ALTO, de hacer un alto útil
en un mundo que va muy rápido,
pero con un destino poco claro,
en una sociedad apurada
por el reloj y el cronómetro,
pero sin una brújula clara.
Y de pronto, la mejor
brújula, el corazón,
y el amor como destino común.
A de ABRAZAR.
Me acuerdo de una chava que me platicaba
que le había agarrado el temblor
en el piso 27 de un edificio
y, cuando pudo bajar,
se moría de ganas de darle un abrazo
a alguien, y al primero que abrazó
fue al jefe de seguridad del edificio,
y luego se hizo una especie
de epidemia de abrazos,
y muchas de estas personas,
cuando habían entrado al edificio,
solo habían visto al guardia
de seguridad de reojo.
Los temblores nos ayudan a ver
personas donde, en la vida cotidiana,
a veces solo vemos uniformes.
A de APRENDER.
De aprender de esa generación
que con su testimonio
no enseñó que se puede reconstruir un país
con un modelo de desarrollo sustentable,
un modelo cuyas energías renovables
son la alegría, la felicidad, la compañía,
la comunidad, el trabajo
y el esfuerzo compartido.
Cómo me sorprendió escuchar
a muchos profesores, maestras,
que no solo hablaban de su miedo y del
miedo que habían vivido en el temblor,
sino de un terror mayor,
del terror a no estar a la altura
de lo que sus alumnos
habían demostrado que eran capaces.
A de ACOMPAÑAR,
de acompañar sin juicio y con compasión.
Un terremoto es un desastre
natural muy democrático,
lo sentimos todos sin importar
código postal,
saldo bancario o nivel socioeconómico,
pero las consecuencias
no siempre son tan democráticas,
dependen de la historia de cada quien
y también a veces dependen
de terremotos sociales previos, que hacen
que los temblores no sean tan equitativos.
A de ACEPTAR.
Aceptar las emociones
y los sentimientos sin juzgarlos.
Qué confortante me resultó aprender
lo inútil y lo absurdo que es
el juicio moral de las emociones.
Eso de poner la etiqueta de emociones
o sentimientos buenos y sentimientos malos,
es como decirle a alguien: "Mira,
está muy bien que tengas hambre,
pero está muy mal que tengas sed".
Las emociones y los sentimientos son guías
y son alertas que nos invitan a la acción.
El terror nos invita a salir corriendo
y a ponernos a salvo.
El miedo nos puede paralizar,
pero el miedo también nos invita
a levantar la mano y a pedir ayuda.
Yo cuando lo vi, lo que vi es
a muchas manos que estaban dispuestas
a ayudar a otros y entrelazarse.
El miedo, en este sentido,
genera comunidad.
A de ALEGRÍA.
Cuando hacíamos encuestas entre
algunos chavos les decíamos a ver,
les íbamos diciendo emociones
y ellos nos decían así con su mano:
poco, regular o mucho.
Y me sorprendió cuando decíamos alegría
que las manos estaban hasta acá,
y cuando les preguntábamos
por qué, nos decían,
porque estamos felices de estar vivos.
A de ALEGRÍA, A de ASOMBRO,
da A de AGRADECER,
lo que a veces la vida nos
regala y que damos por hecho.
B de BUSCAR,
de buscar lo que la vida
nos está preguntando,
buscar ser útiles, buscar a las personas
atrapadas, pero no solo a las personas
atrapadas debajo de una loza de concreto,
sino a los que están atrapados debajo
de los escombros de la indiferencia,
de la soledad, del miedo
y de muchas otras cosas.
Bucear, bucear al fondo de nuestro corazón
para sentir las mismas turbulencias,
las mismas mareas, las mismas
olas que nuestros hermanos.
En los grupos de acompañamiento, cuando
alguien expresaba una emoción sincera,
lo que se veían eran un montón
de miradas, y de cabezas que asentían,
y se ve como una ola, una ola que
sin decir nada, lo que te dice es:
te entiendo, porque yo lo siento igual.
Hay terremotos que provocan tsunamis,
que nos revuelcan con una fuerza horrible,
hay otros temblores que lo que provocan
son olas de cariño, que te abrazan,
te acompañan y te llevan, con cuidadito,
hasta la tierra firme de tus seguridades.
B de BORRAR,
de borrar lo adjetivo para con B,
hacer brillar lo sustantivo.
Cómo me asombraba una amiga que me decía
"yo, cada vez que vamos a estos lugares,
antes del terremoto, a todos
les veía caras de secuestradores,
y después del terremoto y de tener
la oportunidad de conocerlos,
lo que veo son personas valiosas, que
simplemente están buscando igual que yo,
salir adelante".
B de BARRER,
de barrer con los escombros
de lo que no fue firme.
Un señor me decía, se cayó mi edificio,
pero no ese donde yo estaba trabajando,
no, no, no, el mío, el interior,
el que llevaba 50 años construyendo.
Ahora me voy a tener que
reconstruir con cimientos firmes.
C de CALLAR,
de callarnos levantado el puño,
viviendo el silencio que anhela encontrar
lo valioso, y que anhela encontrar vida.
C de CERRAR la boca,
de cerrar la boca para regalar
el silencio que repara, el silencio
que acompaña, el silencio que
te dice lo que ninguna palabra
puede alcanzar a decir.
C de COMUNIDAD,
de comunidad que le gana a la soledad.
Cuando la vida pregunta, y pregunta
fuerte, no se puede contestar
en la primera persona del singular,
se tiene que contestar en la primera
persona del plural, en el nosotros.
Una de las anécdotas que más me conmueven
es la de una amiga que platicaba
cómo unos días antes,
con el temblor de Oaxaca,
les habían pedido en la escuela de sus
hijos que compraran unas latas de atún
para las despensas de ayuda.
Y cuando fue al súper, ella pensaba,
¿y una lata de atún puede
hacer la diferencia?
Y luego nos decía, "quién iba a decir
que diez días después se caía mi casa.
Y cuando bajé, en el albergue
donde estaba la despensa,
a buscar algo para la cena de
mis hijos, saqué una lata de atún
que traía un mensaje que
decía: 'ánimo desde Taxco'".
Una lata de atún,
sí puede hacer la diferencia,
porque no solo apaga el hambre
sino que nutre de ánimo y de esperanza
para reconstruirnos y salir adelante.
C de CONVERTIR,
de convertir nuestros
aprendizajes en servicio.
En uno de los libros que más me gusta
de Zorba el griego, Zorba le preguntaba
a su patrón, ¿y tú, en
qué conviertes lo que comes?
Después de todas estas experiencias
y aprendizajes, yo estoy lleno de tareas,
y de preguntas:
¿En qué convertiré mis terremotos?
¿Cómo podré ser una onda sísmica
que salga a poner a prueba
lo que no tiene buena cimentación?
¿Cómo podré ayudar a construir un mundo
con las normas más exigentes de la ética,
de la compañía, de la solidaridad,
del amor y del trabajo?
¿Cómo podré hacerle para tener
un chismólogo interno que me ayude
a ser sensible a los miles
de terremotos diarios, que no se ven,
y que viven muchas
personas a mi alrededor?
¿Cómo podré hacerle para no regresar
a la indiferencia de lo cotidiano,
y poder seguir viviendo
en modo terremoto?
vulnerable, sensible y útil.
La mejor estrategia que
he encontrado para eso
ha sido seguir siendo aprendiz,
y tratar de rodearme de buenos maestros.
Les comparto lo que
me enseñó una de ellas.
Una amiga que nos decía que su
mayor ilusión era hacer una maestría,
pero como se había caído su casa, con eso,
se derrumbaba también ese proyecto.
Se ve que es súper estudiosa y
súper responsable porque nos platicaba
cómo disfrutaba hacer sus trabajos
en ese espacio privado
y exclusivo que era su cuarto.
Y luego nos decía, después del
terremoto, mis últimos trabajos
los hice acostada en el suelo,
en unas hojas de papel que llegaron
con las despensas, y que tuve que poner
a secar al sol porque se habían mojado
con la lluvia.
Mi amiga Fanny fue el mejor
promedio de su generación,
y hoy, a unos meses del terremoto,
está en Milán haciendo un postgrado
con una beca que se ganó.
Yo quisiera que esta plática sirviera
para decir gracias y hacer un homenaje
a estos maestros que
me han enseñado que las pesadillas
se pueden convertir en sueños,
cuando hay la alquimia de la comprensión
del cariño, de la comunidad
y la ilusión compartida.
Que las pesadillas se pueden convertir
en sueños cuando despertamos
para vivir en modo terremoto, conscientes,
vulnerables, sensibles y útiles.
Que las pesadillas
se pueden volver sueños,
se pueden convertir en sueños,
cuando despertamos para movernos
y para conmovernos con las ondas sísmicas
del corazón de los nuestros.
Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)